okay so that's how we're used to seeing
the god of thunder but for those who saw
Avengers in game there was a much softer
side of Chris Hemsworth took a little
getting used to that Thor was one of the
great surprises of Avengers in game and
now we get to see just how they turned
Chris from this to this
we had a big sheet of fat suit which I
think was sort of 60 or 70 pounds it was
the hottest I've ever been and we had
mommy to the beard the hair and how
these things that go in the mouth that
kind of plump up my cheeks a bit
the reason the gag worked so well was
because we all know Chris's body is
perfectly in shape actually it was when
Chris was cast as door that led to his
body transformation you know before the
thorah never even hadn't lifted White's
really it was my workouts it consisted
of boxing and surfing boxing and surfing
sure but he's also carving a new path of
workouts involving his family including
dance jump rope and even archery so is
there anything he well well actually yes
there is soccer
Chris definitely good evening can't do
soccer
oh wait he actually playing soccer there
cuz I didn't notice anything but Chris
I'm gonna tell you out
[Music]